the white house repeatedly saying that
it's time for congress to fix the broken
system with that we bring in republican
florida republican congressman michael
waltz congressman great to have you with
us today
i want to start with this from moments
ago in the white house briefing room
this is the press secretary karina
jean-pierre when she was asked about
these republican governors transporting
migrants to other states watch this
republican governors interfering in that
process and using migrants as political
pawns
is
shameful
is reckless
and just plain wrong
and remember these are people who are
fleeing communism who are fleeing
hardship
congressman welcome good to have you
with us tonight uh
what's your reaction to that from the
white house this just about an hour ago
yeah thanks martha you know i i would
say you know what is shameful you know
what is wrong is for the vice president
of the united states kamala harris to
say
sit before the nation uh on the sunday
shows and and say the border secure
which is an absolute lie
and
i mean anybody with any common sense uh
can see that it's not and then to say
that we're going to go after the root
causes by advocating for billions of
dollars
to go into central america when we know
that the cartels take anywhere from 20
to 30 percent
the gov corrupt governments take 20 to
30 percent you're actually feeding the
problem into a negative spiral that's
making it worse and on the governor's
look
this is an issue of fairness martha why
is it fair
for all of these border cities the
uvaldes the san antonios the el paso's
to have to absorb this crisis whether
it's their hospitals their schools their
roads or bridges
but all of these cities in chicago
martha's vineyard boston new york
shouldn't have to deal with it this is a
basic issue of fairness and they're
feeling so just a fraction of the pain
that all of our border cities and our
border states have been feeling
yeah you know i'm so struck by the
hypocrisy
of this whole thing because these
individuals from the border they've been
being sent across the country for a long
time i mean we spoke back in april to uh
representative astorino in new york and
when he was upset about what was going
on with planes landing in the middle of
the night none of these same governors
said anything that they didn't they
weren't upset that these planes were
going there watch rob astorino back in
april folks at home
these secret flights were coming from el
paso and mcallen texas into westchester
county airport and other regional
airports in the dead of night and i was
asking questions i have a letter that i
sent february first to the president
wanting to know
who's coming in where they're being
placed if their kids and some of them
are what schools who's paying for this
obviously we are the taxpayers
yep yeah so i don't remember
representatives from martha's vineyard
or dc
or manhattan and any of them being upset
about this when he was talking about it
congressman
yeah those are biden administration
taxpayer-funded contracts with a number
of ngos that are flying these people in
the dead of night to all of these same
locations then it's fine but if you have
governor desantis or governor abbott or
governor ducey doing it in the middle of
the day where everyone can see it then
suddenly we're up in arms we're having a
collective political meltdown the only
difference is this is for
all of the taxpayers to see rather than
sneaking them in either way all of those
services that american citizens and
legal immigrants deserve are now being
taxed
by millions and millions and millions of
people
that we just can't afford to feed and
house and clothe the entire world
and you hear about the sex trafficking
and the drugs coming across the border
that film illusion reports on every day
i don't see it a lot in other networks
but you know what is what is the vice
president doing about those root causes
i mean it's okay to move people around
the country to share the burden but the
bottom line is that you've got hundreds
of thousands of godaways and all these
drugs that nobody seems to be doing
anything about in washington
you know what you want to get it you
want to get at the root causes take on
the cartels this should be at the top of
the agenda with china that's producing
the fentanyl we ought to use military
assets after those cartels uh by the way
and reinstitute uh the remain in mexico
policy while these people wait for their
asylum tapes those are root causes
instead we have a massive tractor beam
an incentivization mechanism for these
people to make this very dangerous
journey and 30 to 40 percent of the
girls making it are sold into human
trafficking or sexually assaulted yeah
that is just a humanitarian crisis and
it's absolutely wrong
[Applause]
it's one of the most tragically
undercovered stories in this whole thing
and we have covered it and we really
want people to continue to shed light on
it i know you have too uh because it's
atrocious that it's happening in this
country congressman thank you always
great to have you with us martha yeah
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now